[Music]
there's a united states representative
who is currently um embroiled in a
scandal no way um
well he cheated on his wife no way
powerful people that have a lot of
options
probably going to cheat male or female
got a lot of hush money i mean
celebrities do it all the time what part
do you think he is he has three dollars
by the way what party is yeah what party
the donkey one green party the
libertarian i think he's a death the tea
party birthday he's a republican jesus
christ okay damn it
we're all wrong [ __ ] i should have
picked one of the two possibilities left
or right donkey party what the [ __ ] is
that
this guy this guy gets with a chick okay
yeah
they're they're having sick
i love this dude they're having this
organization to try and
de-radicalize a lot of like you know
isis fighters and stuff like that by
seducing them no no no no so so he meets
her at this club for that
because she is actually an isis bride
okay so her
dude is that like a basketball wife
close but her her dude went her dude
like left and went to go fight with isis
and he's american he's american
and so she's like an isis um what do you
call it like like um widow oh [ __ ] so
then she she meets this cat uh the con
the representative at this meeting like
hey let's you know we're trying to
see where people are getting to be
extremists and kind of like suss them
out and like help them right yeah okay
so he he said he's they're supposed to
have a 15-minute meeting
kind of goes pretty well it's due
crushed they're like uh hey you know
what this is a pretty interesting topic
we kind of extend this meeting and this
is what this chick looks like by the way
so it was they were talking about
interesting things she looks like she
looks like she has tattoos over her
eyelids and she's just closing her eyes
like she's
trying to sleep during a meeting
she looks like like an old school
egyptian painting like you know like in
the [ __ ] piece that's cool
but she does look like someone painted
eyeballs it went like this she's like
sitting through a lecture with the eye
of law
yeah do you have any swimsuit pictures
of her
yeah yeah we need a better look do you
have any swimsuit pictures of her
instagram
one step at a time so after this the
representative starts to um he gives her
his number he's like we should
definitely keep in touch about this
entire situation this entire topic over
and over i bet he said it like that too
yeah that guy's cool guys she's very
annoying yeah very professional about it
yeah
so then
um pretty quickly she tells him that she
finds him attractive oh oh so she's the
first one to make the move yo this is a
sting bro this is a [ __ ] she's
getting he's getting honey dicks
can we see a photo of him yeah yeah stud
muffin i i might as well just show you
here this is a picture of him
[Laughter]
do
[Music]
yeah i would like to see that for
reference
send it to him i'll send it to you
the court has to see both of those and
what's his tick tock content like it's
very right wing he's very very right
right wing dancing yeah right-wing so in
one in one extremely graphic text
that um sexton the congressman sent to
her
he requested a quote
a long slow rim jump wait wait mike
yes now i'll show you what this guy
looks like oh [ __ ] up oh now you show us
yeah i'm going to show you what it looks
like wait you requested a long slow rim
job the question is did they did he get
it though cause
i don't know but like they had an affair
right it doesn't say what did they have
on the hair i'm waiting for steve to
just show us an app before you show
before you show i have a question for
joe really quick i don't care what he
looks like before you like uh court
another lady for the first time do you
lead with rib job like that or do you
kind of
yeah something you grow but but if
this guy's a little forward but i talk
about it all the time it's not a mystery
he doesn't have a lot of time long slow
rim job
he looks like a bootleg mad tv character
had sex with [ __ ] mr rogers y'all see
i don't know
i didn't know he'd like butt play like
that he i'm telling you guys it's the
new blow job it's the new blow job why
do all these senators look so creepy
they look so weird looking he represents
us dude you take it easy sorry sir he's
california not my president you're not
california don't be saying oh what the
[ __ ] out of here bro
nevada dude you [ __ ] accomplish the
justice texas the great state of texas
so uh yeah now he's probably going to
lose i guess he's a backboard ted cruz
probably going to back out and lose a
pretty big time he didn't really get to
back out because
she didn't take his back out wait so she
leaked the she leaked the text messages
is that what you call it when your chick
is can you take my back out baby
take it out uh yeah so she got tired of
seeing his face all around town because
um they broke off the affair after a
while and she's driving around town
seeing him campaign and [ __ ] and she's
like i'm sick of this [ __ ] this is not
the perfect family man [ __ ] this [ __ ] so
she she called you know how many times i
licked this fool's ass
my question is how did a guy like that
get with such a hot freaking cleopatra
of a woman i don't know man it's crazy i
think she was in a vulnerable place when
her when her husband's vulnerable like
super lonely and this dude was probably
tugging on those heart strings and knew
and what club where would you see both
of them in the same [ __ ] club it's
not [ __ ] hard fast
it's not electric daisy carnival like i
can't believe someone would use power to
get ass
i really can't i'm just curious
i'm just curious what club oh the power
was attractive so it was more like was
it using power to give it it was an
anti-extremism oh
man i thought it was a [ __ ] night
like a like a lounge clash rizzo
loud it was a right wing
it was a hookah rim job lounge that
makes sense that's like a key club
that's a nerd club that makes sense well
key club is also a club out here what is
the key club anyway yeah that was the a
part the a part is like hey this is
anti-watch
yeah i thought it was like omnia or like
you want to talk about terrorism
what
okay my husband left me for isis
he's like hang on one second i got to
push all the water out of my [ __ ]
getting clean and clean for you so you
think i'm attractive no i said this is
entrapment
what are you drinking there's like water
it's going right up my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so yeah um okay
that's fun though i mainly just wanted
to do the story because of the rim jump
thing so there you go and that was for
joe there you go so so just to get the
timeline right just so i'm familiar uh
this had happened previously and then he
started campaigning october 2020
to june 2021 now he's running for
re-election okay because he's already he
already had his power and he was meeting
with her as part of this like
anti-extremism group slash rim job
parlor you know i think
we need to normalize rim jobbing because
i think this scandal is because there's
a stigma against rim job versus [ __ ]
because if this guy was getting
mobilized rim jobs no one's going to be
like oh let's not vote him in because
he's getting [ __ ]
people are just [ __ ] rim job phobic
is what it is and they're like i'm not
voting this far he gets rim jobs why
don't you do something about it you have
a show you have a bar for man i'm
spreading awareness and my own legs no
but i'm saying
you should buy a spot on your own show
so when you're doing when you're doing
careful boys off the record for the 10
minutes so yeah you can you can sell
people on the new blow job this video is
brought to you by [ __ ] rim jobs it's
a psa um
let's normal life
[Music]
have you heard of the rusty trombone and
then i want bart's like enthusiasm
really you gotta check out rimjobs he's
like i'm telling you guys not really my
style but i'm sure it's fun
spread awareness and cheeks and my butt
what's the most optimal way to receive a
rim job is it laying down legs up yeah
or are you doing one of these things
you're the dog i'm the dog that's cool
oh do you have a call it's called
greeting at the dog park i mean you guys
both look like dogs if that's the
position yeah how do you how do you how
do you feel
how do you feel safe with with her back
there
how are you do you wear a helmet with
the [ __ ] side mirror like this so you
can see what the hell is going on hey
what are you doing back there
look at your nest cam
you're watching it while you do your
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i i well sometimes
i just
no she has the doctor's thing
or i grab the bed sheets and i
scrunch up the bed sheets and i put it
in my mouth and i have something to bite
on
what's the thread count on those
[ __ ] i feel so uh
this side of the table man
that [ __ ] got too real why are you doing
that kind of [ __ ] like the bed sheet
no this is you gotta you gotta get the
bed sheet you gotta make it into a ball
like this like this [ __ ] ball right
and then there's a grip
i think we got it i think we got it
that's the old-timey [ __ ] dude it's
old-timey
i hope i don't see no wrinkles in your
bed sheets when i come over no we iron
them out dude that must be the ultimate
[ __ ] embarrassment though when your
sex go out like that oh cause that's the
worst time you imagine if somebody
[ __ ] got a hold of your old aim
[ __ ] conversations when you first
didn't know how to do that and you said
the weirdest [ __ ] to people through
that's politics right especially when
you get that high level and you already
know you're going against people that
are competing against that's why i don't
understand why [ __ ] politicians even
use regular texts they think they're
powerful they're they they're just so
they think they won't get got yeah yeah
why i'm gonna run for politics that's
right because i'm already planning this
is my you're gonna run for politics just
general right now i'm joe tatsukawa and
i'm running for
joe just call endorses his message
i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna play
politics
because i already have you guys here
jojo's guy was running for politics i
already have this [ __ ] on luck all right
you know what's gonna happen is no one
can [ __ ] beat me because i already
[ __ ] beat myself
what about that ukraine dude they got
all these comedy videos popping up now
but he's funny that's like jimmy kimmel
right like like somebody that's like
safe all right this is this is joe's
campaign poster
[ __ ]
come on man a small man is they can cut
it if they want to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you